[Music]
everything is great
Dwayne Johnson dishes on fatherhood and
whether he set up Nick Jonas and
Priyanka Chopra I did it he caught up
with the skyscraper star and his
director rawson marshall thurber ahead
of the release of their new action film
and Dwayne couldn't help but smile over
his friends and Baywatch co-stars
budding romance you brought Nick and
Priyanka together true are they happy
yeah they're happy they watching a
Jumanji yes you become I did the 46 year
old actor also opened up about family
life with longtime girlfriend Lauren
hash Ian and their two daughters two
month old Tia and two-year-old Jasmine
oh she's doing so good thank you so much
yes she's doing great
mama Lauren is doing great baby T is
getting big baby jazzy is loving her
little sister just yeah everything I did
not okay
no no I did not just I refer to as my
wife all the time that's what a lot of
people like I'm like no easy rush Big
Daddy I ask you guys a question
daddy loves to me dad loves it exactly
that is gonna go make that bacon gross
miss movies also about family yeah how
important is it and it has heart and
it's one of those things that you could
take everybody to see and I think
everyone will enjoy oh thanks yeah well
I mean look at the skyscrapers are
really fun action movie it's suspenseful
suspenseful if you're um you know if
you're afraid of heights you know it's a
pretty intense
take a friend if you're afraid of
heights that's what it really is about
family and it's about
you know what would you do if your
family was in trouble how far would you
go so this movie has a lot of heart in
it it's centered on family and also to
this movie was inspired by a movies that
I we both loved as a kid and when movies
that inspired generations die hard
that hurt towering inferno a fugitive a
little bit a fugitive a cliffhanger you
know that one right after the war
picture yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]